hello everyone and welcome back to binge
battle my name is mark ellis and the
book on boba fett is now closed well the
the first book was we got our chapters
we loved them we debated them and they
were always trending on twitter and so
what better topic to have today as we
anticipate this obi-wan series coming
out the book of boba fett just closing
up shop we
are going to talk all things boba fett
and there will be some spirited
competitive debate here with two great
star wars minds and i say that as that
it applies to this galaxy or any other
one so fair warning spoilers aplenty
will be happening if you've not seen the
book of boba fett or the mandalorian or
really anything in that galaxy far far
away then you might want to go check
some of that stuff out then come on back
because we're going to get deep into the
chapters of the book of boba fett thanks
again for coming back to binge battle
for all of us here at rotten tomatoes it
is my pleasure to welcome our guests
today up first needs no introduction
especially if you've ever met him at a
comic con because he is just one of
those folks that knows things and you
can check out his youtube channel heroes
reforge where he does all sorts of
reviews and reactions and just great
content that seems like it's almost
daily or maybe that's just how i watch
it he is adam blavik adam you are on the
show for your very first time welcome
sir and when we're talking about debuts
here's my question to you when you were
just a wee tyke and you were watching
this star wars stuff for the first time
when you met boba fett on screen what
was your initial reaction do you
remember it at all was he cool was he
just so unmemorable who was boba fett to
you that's a great question first of all
thank you for having me i'm excited to
be here i definitely thought you were
teeing up ken when you first started
talking
um in terms of boba fett
i remember seeing the empire strikes
back in theaters in 97 with the
re-release
so i didn't know too much about boba
fett before that because that was my
introduction to star wars but i was
definitely intrigued by the design of
the character and that seems to kind of
be
the catch-all answer for everyone is the
design was really really cool
so that was my introduction and then
returned the jedi he was so short-lived
but then i started jumping into the
expanded universe and learning a little
bit more about that character and then
as it as it was you know his history
kind of became more solidified with the
prequel so
it was really cool to kind of see this
character who was kind of short-lived in
the movies end up having sort of a
second life in the prequels and then we
thought oh we'll probably never see this
character again and now we got this show
and then you know he showed up in the
mandalorian spoilers which i thought was
a really really cool way to reintroduce
this character so i've always had this
like fondness and intrigue for this
character so i'm so happy that we got
this show to give us even more context
and i i hope that that continues in the
future a great answer unfortunately to
dock you a point for having your first
time seeing star wars being the
re-releases i you know we have young
people on theatrical experience it was
pretty great when i was in high school
going back to go see the re-releases and
so now you're gonna know who i'm
introducing now adam because this next
competitor and your opponent
almost got into a comic-con party in
2016 and he's also a very funny comedian
he hosts pop rocking radio on mix cloud
and he knows a thing or two about star
wars as well so you can check out his
popular podcast for center he is a
returning favorite to binge battle ken
knapsock you're back hello sir and your
first introduction to boba fett i think
it might have take place a little bit
before adams
yeah yeah my dad hadn't even bought our
family's first microwave yet uh that's
that's how long ago yeah no for me it's
return of the jedi and again mark happy
to be back here uh debating my favorite
california burrito buddy adam holavic uh
boba fett for me was the guy tried to
hurt my little han and and paid for it
as he should have by being launched into
the sarlacc pit that was my first
introduction seeing jedi first and
working my way back so i always had a
wonderful and but yet interesting
relationship with both fit the design
was cool but he was there for so long
for so short of time and i liked that
because you don't go after luke and han
in my world when i was seven you know
again the old comedian code that we have
is you're supposed to leave them wanting
more and boba fett certainly did that in
the classic trilogy know i would even
say in in the prequels that we got to
meet the daddy of boba fett and have
some fun adventures but then we just
really saw boba fett holding that helmet
and then it was a nice nod to what we
had already known and where would it go
from here but the biggest question on
everyone's lips when it came to boba
fett is did he survive the fall into the
sarlacc pit luke knocked him in there
did he survive is it officially canon we
got a lot of cool looking trailers that
were fan made we got some novels and
some comic books that may not have been
canon when disney bought in 2012 but now
it was finally official that the book of
boba fett was happening and thus he did
get out of the sarlacc pit and wow you
want to talk about a claustrophobic
scene welcoming you to what the
starlight pill looks like from the
inside i don't think we would have made
it out of there but now we are here and
we are debating so here is how it works
each competitor is going to get a minute
opening statement about whatever topic i
feel like bringing up first and then
once that happens they'll have about a
30 second rebuttal period and then a
10-second closing statement and then it
is up to me to make a judgment between
my two dear friends as to who had the
better war waged in that particular
topic round so here we go with topic
number one and it is
which was the best episode chapter the
best episode of the book of boba fett
can napstock you have the first opening
statement a minute or less boba fett nod
to you sir my favorite episode uh and
therefore what i feel is the best
without a doubt is chapter two the
tribes of tatooine directed by steph
green of course john favreau getting
writing credit for all these episodes
here other than the one he split with
felony i love this episode because this
whole series is about change it's about
growth it's about someone trying to
reconcile the trauma from his past and
to do that you have to confront fear
which is big in star wars uh the goals
of the jedi are to confront fear uh fear
leads to anger suffering hate all those
things we've heard before and chapter 2
is about this big question of what do
you fear we spent a lot of time with the
tuscans who know the land who know
tatooine so well uh they they know what
uh what the dangers the pitfalls of that
land but then they fear something that's
an outsider of the pikes the interlopers
the train boba fett helps them confront
that and then they in turn help him
confront and come to terms with his
trauma his past what he's going through
his identity he's uh he's a son of jango
fett he became a bounty hunter because
of his father perhaps but he was
rudderless some of the best boba fett
content is the clone wars when he's a
youngster with cadman and rsing taking
him under his wing uh but he has to
confront all that trauma there as well
is he a clone is he a mandalorian is he
a son of django who is he he has great
fear uh from all of that stuff and that
episode is about that big question what
do you fear and then therefore how can
you overcome it uh it has some of the
most beautiful stuff the tuscans that
moved a lot of people there's a lot of
passions around what happened to the
tuscans uh after totally understandable
different kind of debate uh but i think
that episode was just beautiful bold and
and and different for star wars thus far
yes some uprisings emotional uh
you really got the feels in that episode
and i don't think that after the show
i'm ever going to go back to people like
obi-wan and call them sand people again
they're tuscan raiders and now we go to
adam for your opening statement ken
took chapter two what says mr slavic i
went with chapter six from the desert
comes a stranger this is the dave filoni
directed co-written with john favreau
episode
and the big reason why i picked this one
was i know that the immediate sort of uh
reaction from people seemed like well
it's the one that has boba fett probably
in it the least but the thing for me
that made it such an impactful episode
was the fact that it is culminating so
many different eras of star wars and so
many different
parts of a such a vast universe and it
worked so flawlessly and i know dave
filoni is someone who is so passionate
about the entire universe and you feel
that from every single scene going
through from mando to then the huge
revelations of luke and grogu ahsoka and
it's tying in all these things so
beautifully and i think for me what it
does is that it brings so much
anticipation for what the finale is
going to be and it raises so many
questions it also raises the stakes
tremendously because now you're seeing
the inner workings of the pike syndicate
you're seeing the inner workings of what
it means when you try to go against the
pike syndicate and the the integration
of someone like cad bane a character who
if you've been following star wars for
the last 15 16 20 years almost that is a
character that you've come to know
through clone wars who's then referenced
in so many other different things so to
finally see all those things come to
fruition and come on screen and to see
characters sharing those sequences
together it brings you bring your
personal emotion to to it but also the
anticipation and even if you don't know
those characters as well
the way that dave filoni crafts that
episode and the intensity that you feel
between cad bane
and and the marshall cobb van and just
how it elevates and escalates from scene
to scene to scene it just makes it that
much more anticipated for the finale and
i feel like without that piece
there is no way for the finale to really
work yes you have plenty of other things
that happen beforehand but this is
really the centerpiece of the season
that if these things don't come together
flawlessly and you're not you're not out
of breath by the end of the episode
you're going into the finale and the
anticipation just isn't as high i'm just
excited to re-watch this show now you're
talking about that being a staple at
conventions dave filoni when he's
wearing that fedora that is a really fun
guy to talk star wars with so can we go
back to you and as a great catcher for
the evil empire once said when there's a
fork in the road take the fork you have
a fork in the road sir you have a
rebuttal you can either continue your
argument with chapter two why it's great
or you can maybe throw some barbs adam's
way and say this is why two is better
than six uh i love celebrating star wars
not tearing it down adam's choice is
wonderful you can't go wrong cad bane's
one of my favorite characters i just
love big themes in star wars and i love
how you connect i keep talking about the
fear one there but some of the beautiful
stuff with the tuscan raiders you're
right i call them the tuscans of the
dunes see now i feel guilty calling him
anything about that um
it was something that's uh i think very
powerful in star wars uh that that mix
of we always say in four center joseph
and i uh we love this idea of star wars
being about generational change uh
taking what is old and combining it with
new and recon just adding
you know recontextualizing things and
the tuscan raider stuff is so beautiful
it gets into their culture it gets into
how it affects its cultural exchange
it's boba fett learning this big concept
of i can't go alone anymore the
importance of of a tribe and it was
something bold and different for star
wars at that time and taking something
we grew up with boba fett we're taking
boba fett and changing him but now it's
taking something that we grew up with
for a long time our views of the tuscans
views of tatooine i always say you go
back to tatooine to learn more about
star wars and every time you check in on
tatooine you're learning something new
about this franchise you fell in love
with and so i think that's why it was
something bold and and that vision
everything at the end with the wood and
and and boba fett kind of connecting
with his weapon later on i think it sets
up a lot of the big core themes for the
show so i'll stand behind uh chapter two
and not tear down chapter six all right
well i am with ken give us all the sandy
planets star wars dune spaceballs i will
comb the desert and now
adam's turn to comb for
episode six or against episode two
thirty seconds
is there is there a world where i can
mix and match both
have at it sir aaron build terrorism
well i would say the one thing that is
and it's and i and i and i hate saying
it only because i do agree that episode
two is really good but i feel like the
only thing that kind of takes away from
that is the fact that by the end of the
season we never really address that any
of that stuff ever again and that to me
is one of the things that's one of the
low points of the show which is a bummer
and i think with episode six what it
does is that it's able to take
everything that it introduces
and it sets up grogoo's future it sets
up the potential showdown of two
characters that even though we've never
seen it before on screen we know that it
exists in some form or fashion so to be
able to set up all these things and to
actually deliver on those things deliver
on the promise that was set up to me
felt very very very fulfilling and not
only that it again just plays into the
intricacy of star wars and how much
depth there really is and you know a lot
of people talk about tatooine and
tattooing too much tatooine but you
really realize just how intricate and
how pivotal this planet is to this
entire universe and it's not just about
the core characters that we found out
about in six or seven movies
it's really about the entire universe
like that planet for whatever reason is
really pivotal to the universe itself so
i think that
learning all of that and having that
much pressure on it and then introducing
all these things around it to then
support boba fett into the finale
was the reason like why i felt like it
was such a strong episode yeah it built
on what we already had then it's set up
some more stuff for the future do not
eat pretzels when you're watching book
of boba fett it's just gonna make you
even thirstier all right ken you got a
quick final statement to support chapter
two here's the thing about chapter two
it's just this wonderful tone poem that
uh can connect to your life not just
star wars adam's not wrong about uh
chapter six connecting the rest of star
wars i just a lot of times now in my
life fine star wars is is my church and
i took a lot of inspiration and uh
lessons from chapter two and that's why
i love it all right adam last word on
chapter six goes to you uh last word i
would say is that whether or not you're
a massive star wars fan i think it's a
very fulfilling experience and i think
seeing all these worlds collide and
seeing all these new things pop up i
think it really just makes your entry
grow immensely about the world of star
wars so i think it's a really good hook
to get people even deeper into the lore
and on top of that it's building up
towards a really really great finale oh
this is going to be the whole show isn't
it this is this is really tough these
were two great
just not even debates because y'all were
just stumping for your episodes and
that's again why we love celebrating and
building up star wars we don't want to
be that kid that again if you're
building sand castles on tatooine you
don't want to be the boy that's knocking
them down you want to help support and
so to make a decision here
it's a tough one but i look at it like
this where the book of boba fett
two and six are two of my favorite
episodes as well i think that the reason
why six works so well is because we
even though we didn't get a lot of boba
fett we got so much of boba fett in
episode sue and like ken said we really
did get to explore that character
because we wanted to know who this
person was at some point you have to be
more than just cool looking armor and
wow did we get so much more of an
emotional impact than i expected and you
talk about how cool boba fett looked but
we didn't really know him i just thought
the tuscan raiders were just they were
just mean they did they hit luke and
we're like oh i don't like them and now
i've come to love them i want to join
the truck i want to get in there i want
my own stick one day and so as
if you ever had a four second
conversation with me you know how much i
love luke skywalker but i'm going with
ken's argument here for chapter two so
ken gets the nod early and he is up in
life well we already knew that and on
this show one to nothing which means
that we go into topic two and that is
going to be the best character and for
that we go to adam who's looking to even
up the scoreboard adam round two is here
and your character for the best in book
of boba fett is this was an easy one for
me this is the titular character himself
boba fett played by tamara morrison for
me it was kind of the everything that
ken explained in the last topic is kind
of the reason why i chose boba fett the
fact that we had a character who was
really nothing in the star wars universe
if you really boil it down he was
nothing he was just a character who made
a cameo he looked really cool and that
was it
through clone through the uh attack of
the clones and clone wars you know we
get a little bit more context but now we
get to see a character and and
mandalorian as well now we get to see a
fully fledged character we get to
understand why boba fett is the way he
is you get little hints into his
backstory things that we hadn't seen
before but more importantly we get to
see what
he goes through after he suffers
something as traumatic as going through
the sarlacc pit and i think that with a
combination of what he goes through
while he's living with the tusken
raiders for three four years it's kind
of unclear but he learned so much about
kindness and empathy and just
understanding and an open mindedness and
a willingness to understand and a
willingness to communicate which is
something that really really surprised
me because he's built up to be such a
cold-hearted bounty hunter to see him be
empathetic and to see him embrace
the tuscan culture and for them to
embrace him it really speaks to this
character's
willingness to go on a path of
redemption not just for himself but also
for everybody around him you know he
really dedicates himself to wanting to
better the lives of everybody on
tatooine yes mas espa firstly but
everyone else and that includes trying
to get rid of the pike syndicate and i
think that every episode that we see him
in there's more progress more progress
more progress the flashbacks support
that and so by the time you get to the
end of the series when he defeats cad
bane it's one of the most fulfilling
moments of the first season and i think
one of the most fulfilling moments in
star wars because you have if you have
that history and that knowledge with you
know kind of what all that means and
it's such a great pivotal moment for him
and you you cheer for a character that
originally in the in the original
trilogy you probably wouldn't have done
done for and i think that is a huge
testament to the writing and the way
that it's performed by tamara morrison
in the intimate moments the action
moments you know everything in between
so that that's why boba fett was my
number one guy it's a great point you
bring up because yeah like you're
watching the show and i love that it
doesn't give you a definite time frame
on how long he is hanging out with the
with the the people of tuscany however
ken what's he saying is
it it was a week was it a decade but i
don't need to know that i just love how
much they hung out and again there's a
lot of hanging out because there's not
the tv to watch there's not a starbucks
to go to
your favorite character are you taking
somebody who's camping out are you
taking somebody who's more city bound
look mark this is like a sports thing
here i'm up against a great defense i
might as well throw some hail mary's
boba fett it's in the book of mobile
event it's spectacular everything adam's
saying i'm like yeah that's great he's
right so i went with the hell mary of
someone who i think kind of stole some
scenes and connects to uh what the show
was trying to do and that is the
wonderful jennifer beals i'm a maniac
that's for sure as garsa flip the owner
and operator of the sanctuary uh there
on hamas espa uh one of the things that
this show was trying to do is talk about
these uh would they use tatooine for
this they're trying to break this cycle
they're trying to break the cycle of
pain this underworld uh that's dominated
destroyed the communities of mos iceland
uh las espango and tatooine and she
represents that she's twilight which is
definitely uh has uh some associations
in star wars with being uh part of the
slave trade part of the pleasure trade
part of people
a people uh who don't have control of
their own lives don't have agency uh
we've seen great characters who've
overcome that champs and doula harrison
doula but but garcia flip comes along
and she isn't uh she's providing not
just pleasure not just distractions
she's providing a new way and that all
comes to a head for me with that great
scene with chris santon one of my
favorite characters show up in the show
and he's fighting drunk and he's
fighting transitions who hasn't done
that at the comedy club in their life
and that great monologue that's turned
into a great meme of just like you you
were a great champion you used to people
used to cheer for you to rip arms off
but that was the old way this is the new
way and i i really believe that's a
theme in life and a theme in star wars
don't fight change find your place in
change and she represents that as the
people of tatooine all come together in
chapter seven to break the cycle of pain
and and suffering uh that has uh been uh
on a tatooine for generations and so she
represents a big core theme plus she
looks great and these wonderful twilight
outfits these custom-designed uh
gowns and dresses she's glamorous and
wonderful and that great line hit it max
that is uh my favorite line of the
series yeah i'm sure a lot of folks
watching this show had that same
experience watching book of boba fett
where it's like hey who is that that
look oh my god that's flash dance that's
jennifer
holy crap and it's a great choice as you
said
not the titular character but wow what a
scene stealer so we go back to adam to
stump more for boba fett who we know and
now love well yeah i would say that that
without boba fett obviously the series
doesn't work right because he's the
teacher character but more importantly
than that because i feel like that's an
easy cop-out i think it's the emotional
journey that the character goes on and i
think what his journey does for us as
the viewer
is it
at least for me when i watch it it
allows for a lot of reflection of like
change
pursuing change openness to change
willingness to change and i think that
again was so surprising for me when it
came to that character was the fact that
this character is so open to changing
you know ken talked a lot about about
change and embracing change and those
things like that and the fact that he's
willing to put his life on the line for
the people of tatooine when he really
has no history with tatooine as far as
we know it's very very minimal from what
we've seen so the fact that he's kind of
willing to put his neck on the line
mostly because of the tuscan people like
that's really the only thing that
motivates him to want to protect and
defend and fight for the people of
tatooine are those moments and those
moments only work if you get to have
those intimate episodes with boba fett
and the tuscan people so i think
all those combinations
are the reason why you stay the whole
reason why you constantly watch the
reason why you're invested in the
character's story and that's that's why
ultimately again another reason for why
i feel so connected to that character in
this show
it's a great message of embracing change
here on this program nothing stays the
same unchained but ken as you mentioned
the first time we met spy likes in the
classic trilogy they were serving jabba
either as the the the right hand or
dancing for him and being rancor bait i
mean they really had a tough go but
garsa flip trying to flip that script
yeah and and what happens is she dies
it's tragic it's sad and we don't know
if max rebo does that's the big mystery
of the series here but the astromech
drummer droid does as well why that was
important why it drives homes
drives home the fact that i thought she
was my favorite character is it it's the
sanctuary it is everything it it is the
big stakes and when it's lost and it's
taken and boba fett i told her as long
as i'm in control i will protect you and
he fails to do that i think it just
drives a lot of the big points home but
again we got boba fett put uh pet and
banta going make beautiful banta babies
i'll take that moment almost over
everything too but garcia's whip is the
heart of the series for me uh what the
series is trying to communicate i'm not
gonna lie to you adam i was watching
that episode where he said go make banta
babies and set the bantha free and i had
molly the wonder dog on my chair with me
and i was like i ain't letting you go
you ain't making any babies you're
staying with papa uh each one of you
gentlemen get a final argument gonna
start with you adam
boba fett riding a rancor
come on man
come on man
that was like
the chef's kiss moment of that series
was the fact that we had that build up
with the awesome danny trejo as the
rancor wrangler
to finally say like i want to ride that
bent into battle and for him to show up
at that at the end
just all that weight all that emotion
and all those things from the whole
season of like the intensity the emotion
the boba fettness the the way that he
embraces all those things and to finally
see him now ride his ride his battalion
into into battle i was like yeah this
worked for me i'm in
season two please thank you
uh ken i can just see all these senior
quotes right now boba fett wrote a
rancor
uh ken your final argument against the
guy who wrote the rancor yeah ranky the
rancor is my one of my favorite
characters in star wars now uh look what
are the one of the
one of the things with boba fett is mark
like you or you and i he's a very stoic
guy it's hard to get to know us right uh
and i still felt at the end of the day i
i still want to know boba fett i want to
sit down he's so stoked he's still
withdrawn he went on this wonderful
journey though garcia flip wore
everything on the sleeve plus she also
knows how to play the power game
everything about her early on if i
didn't see your litter all that kind of
stuff just created some great moments
she's memorable she'll stand the test of
time uh boba fett will always be there
we now have guards of women
one of the really interesting aspects of
the book of boba fett which i appreciate
is that as we've already intimated on
this show is that not every episode made
boba fett the focus in some episodes you
didn't really see boba fett as much as
you did other characters and that's fine
and that's okay and as much as people
may say well why is it called the book
of boba fett there's a lot of chapters
in a book that don't all focus on
whoever the book is named after such as
a garcia flip but at the end of the day
the reason why we kept coming back and
we're just glued to our tvs week after
week is because
we love the mystery but now as we start
to peel back the layers of who boba fett
really is it just got more and more
interesting and like peeling an onion
adam it did make me tear up a few times
and so adam and boba fett and the rancor
get the point here in round two and we
are tied at one apiece and so now we
careen into a very interesting topic
here i love this because it is star wars
we love celebrating what we are going to
love and also what we already love so
the topic for round three is most
surprising
call back ken i've seen you do stand-up
comedy many times you make a few call
backs into your set from time to time
in star wars particularly the book of
boba fett what was the most surprising
callback i love callbacks my my election
of 1912 humor is killing it it's killing
it out there right now no my favorite
thing my favorite callback and it was
really surprising in which how much it
was featured and seems to be like it's
going to be featured going forward it's
the n1 naboo starfighter from 1999 i do
love my prequels it was a long journey
to get to that point like a lot of
people my age i rejected a lot of things
about them early on but one of the
things i always loved was the design of
the n1 starfighter i think a lot of
people do love it and to hear
or to see i should say that that it was
back uh that alone it's cool but then
again you're going to hear this from me
all the time what it represents it
represents this thing for for
mandalorian about embracing the new and
you and connected with it and and his
want is a new razor crest and pele is
like yeah but give this give this
mustang a try man i'll fix it up nice
and i just love that sequence and bryce
dallas howard directed the hell out of
that sequencing i've got so much joy i
love the prequel generation i am so
thankful to them for keeping the flame
of star wars alive when a lot of people
in my generation wanted to stamp it out
and i think to see the n1 naboo
starfighter flying across the sands of
tatooine uh was just beautiful it was
unexpectedly uh emotional and uh i think
again just the way it was shot uh was
just surprising that the fact that an n1
starfighter was there all right that's
good enough but the way it was featured
the way the joy of star wars just well
just shot out of that starfighter as it
shot through uh the atmosphere and up
into space i loved every moment of it
and can't wait to see more
yeah anyone who badmouths the prequels
and i'm not the biggest lover of the
prequels but i will say hey you don't
like the prequels then you have to wait
another 16 years for new star wars
because that's what we all did
not everybody was as lucky as that and
to be born late enough to get the
re-releases then just ride right into
the frequency so adam your most
surprising callback here was it
something from the prequels like ken was
it something from the classic trilogy or
something off the board
i also picked something from the exact
same episode the boon to eve classic
podrace track from the phantom menace
that is
when i saw that
moment the hairs on my arm stood up and
it's really weird because i also like i
like i enjoy the prequels i don't love
them but for whatever reason
my body kicked back into 1999 when i was
12 and i first saw that movie and i felt
like i was a kid in the theater watching
something like unfold that was really
really special and like ken said bryce
alice howard did a phenomenal job
directing that episode
but what i will say
that sequence doesn't work if you don't
have the n1 starfighter and that
was even cooler to me
did he take a kneel down did he take a
knee
he's not out of the game yet but this is
what happens when you get a bunch of
star wars songs in a room when we all
like i i don't want anybody to just look
at a certain social media platform and
say that's what twitter debate i mean
there's a lot of it there but then when
you get into a room and you just start
talking about stars there is so much
love and there's hey that's a great
point that's a great point so
this might as well be the star wars
barbershop and and not binge battle here
today but i will i'll toss it back over
to ken because ken
adam does love the the the starfighter
just like you do and i imagine you also
had some hairs on certain parts of your
body stand up when you saw the classic
track for the booty classic well mark as
you know i shave off arm hair for time
so uh you got to get the edge on the
comedy stage uh the booty eve classics i
love the pod race it's so wild and crazy
and i would have loved a shot of a
memorial for rats tyrell rest in peace
rats uh i absolutely loved it it was a
joy to to see that in a lot of ways and
it's not just simply about going back
adam's not wrong when he says that hey i
felt like i was 12. i think sometimes
people focus on that like it's we're
stuck in nostalgia it's not that it's
connecting to this primal joy that star
wars can bring you if you're that kind
of fan for some people they pass through
the galaxy and it's okay i think seeing
the n1 naboo starfighter was some sort
of confirmation for a generation of star
wars fans that were told your star wars
is less than and to see it featured in
such a way uh as such a loving way by
the creators doug chang who was uh
involved as
one of the longest lucasfilm employees
involved in the creation of the stuff in
the phantom menace era and and now gets
to do it again all these years later uh
bryce dallas howard part of that
generation as as well too i mean her
father was going to direct episode one
at one point the rumor was so to her to
be able to just get back in her skills
supersede any family name by the way i
want her to direct star wars every time
out she's so great i just it was just
this co it was just again confirmation
of the love you had for this wonderful
designed ship from these uh off of the
line movies uh that still have the
spirit of star wars in it but just
that's why it worked for me yeah i have
a feeling that we're to see a lot more
bryce dallas howard in the star wars
galaxy assuming she survives that bout
with dinosaurs because i think she's
battling a few really big ones and i
hear they can fly now like storm
troopers and rise to skywalker there's a
lot of stuff going on in the world of
movies but we go back to this streaming
show for adam lavik's rebuttal you you
saw that track for the first time and
you just got all the feels
yeah and i think it's for a lot of the
same reasons the n1 starfighter you know
you take something like the moon to eve
classic or you take this pod race track
and
i think it does validate a lot of the
feelings that people had when they first
saw episode one and loved it and they
think for the last 20 some odd years you
know there's been a lot of talk on the
internet about people who say the
prequels are such and such sort of
movies and at one point just like
they're trying to do with the sequel
trilogy now they're trying to pretend
like those movies never existed but i
feel like if you really truly want to
love star wars you have to embrace all
of it the good the bad and the ugly and
for me
these types of callbacks
especially to something that was such a
monumental piece of episode one not only
from a storytelling perspective but also
technically for what it did in terms of
the filmmaking and pushing filmmaking
forward you get to revisit this and even
though it's not a pod race just the fact
that you can see a location you can see
two rocks standing next to each other
and you know exactly where you are on
tatooine and you know exactly what that
represents you know exactly what what
what a canyon tunnel represents and you
know exactly what how that made you feel
when you first saw it to me that is like
the power of
yes nostalgia but also revisiting things
that
made you really really really love star
wars and just made you feel really
fulfilled as a kid or a young adult or
whenever you saw it
and
and just giving you a little piece of
history and telling you as the audience
hey we also think that this is cool and
i love that i feel like if you drop the
three of us off anywhere on tatooine
we've seen enough of the planet by this
point i think we know how to get around
and figure out how to get to a watering
hole just don't ask about safe transport
to alderaan
i i i don't want to be the one to break
the news ken your final argument when it
comes to the starfighter
it's it's it comes down to this mark by
the way i i was worried this round that
helvik was calling for the spike but
looking for mark ingram in the corner of
the end zone here um uh it comes down to
this
it was wizard
oh my god
that was the best
yeah
yeah i like these mic drops that we're
getting here and that's a great dan
marino reference too ken adam your final
take on either the pod race track itself
or the m1 starfighter have at it look
they were both amazing like that whole
sequence in and of itself was probably
like one of the coolest moments in this
first season and i think they go hand in
hand and i think they just made my 12
year old self
feel so happy so excited and as someone
who has probably spent more time
defending the phantom menace than i
probably need to on the internet uh it
just made me
just made that all those feelings more
valid and that's why i absolutely love
that whole sequence i love what both you
are saying especially about feeling like
a kid again because look cigarettes are
bad the unfiltered ones are worse but
unfiltered joy that's just that's just
good old-fashioned give it all to me and
one of my favorite moments in star wars
history is the trailer for phantom
menace and i know both of y'all share
that sentiment as well and the thing
that you you get this nice slow build up
with the classic music and then boom
you're in the middle of a pod race all
of a sudden you're like what the hell is
going on so while for me personally it
was the actual pod race track that i i
glommed onto a lot more hearing
primarily ken but also ad i'm talking
about how cold the n1 starfighter is
from naboo i do feel like that is the
one that if i had to give the point with
my head and not my heart it goes to the
author of why we love star wars
celebrating more reasons here today ken
knapsock so ken goes up to two to one
here and adam lavik is fighting
valiantly and now he tries to stay alive
for the sudden death round where we are
is round number four for our next topic
and that is what is the best cameo
in the book of boba fett there are a lot
of them there are a lot of callbacks a
lot of great characters but as far as
the cameos go
gonna
start with you here adam which one is
the best there were so many juicy
choices in this in this season way more
than i thought we were gonna get i
genuinely did not think we'd get as many
the biggest one for me that was my
massive sorry to do christian holy
moment
was the appearance of cad bane that was
one of the most left-field things i
never expected in a million years and as
someone who grew up watching clone wars
some of the references and some of the
other books and rebels to see that
character actually step from animation
into live action and for to look
seamlessly based pretty seamless to what
it looked like in the animated series
was one of the most surprising
and also nostalgic at least for me you
know coming from the world of being a
star wars fan but i think even if you
weren't a star wars fan
you are immediately intrigued by this
cowboy who's coming across the desert
with the sun behind him and you're
thinking okay who is this what is this
character what is this character going
to be about and then he starts talking
and you don't even need to see his whole
face it's literally just corey burton's
voice
and you're hooked you're immediately
hooked and the fact that not only does
this character show up in the second
last episode but then also shows up in
the finale and the moment that he has
with boba fett they have multiple
moments but then the final moment where
they finally face off and you understand
through the episode how deadly this
character is
how lethal he is and how he's willing to
basically do anything for the job
for for the spice like that's really all
his motivation is
and the fact that we get to have such a
an amazingly fulfilling moment with him
and boba fett and the build-up of that
is so intense that your cheeks are tight
when you're watching that episode uh was
so awesome and just so unexpected for me
and i loved loved love seeing him show
up in this show yeah you know we always
talk about how star wars oh it's cool
because it feels like a western it's
hard to get more western than a
character like cad bane so ken how do
you counter what is your best cameo in
the book of boba fett so far i mean
kanban's one of my favorite characters
give him the round i'm kidding
i absolutely love cafe and there's so
many choices there's character cameos
and and then there's this classic kind
of actor cameo and that happens a lot i
mean steven root showing up and asking
for uh his stapler to be moved is uh
returned is great um i went with danny
trejo as the rancor keeper yeah i would
have loved malakili there as well the
original ranker keeper but here's the
thing that danny trejo would show up in
a robert rodriguez rodriguez directed
episode is not a surprise their their
their collaborators their family that
it's not a surprise at all but the use
of danny trejo was beautiful again
talking about the court he is this
rancor keeper in this amazing scene with
boba fett someone who wants to change
but he's been raised uh at a certain way
he's gone through the galaxy thinking
almost like he has to be something and
danny trejo comes along to say that what
you are and what people think you are
does not have to be who you are and then
he teaches him that through the rancor
this creature that we all grown up that
is slurping down gamorean guards killing
oola being a threat to luke skywalker
it's this monster and here's danny trejo
to say no that's what it looks like but
that's not who this creature is you
could be something else in fact the boba
fett reacts to him like
this this trained killer can feel
if he can feel i can feel does that
justify the way i am around and to use
danny trejo who has this wonderful
career by the way i'm a big fan of
trejo's tacos not a sponsor but i'd like
them to be for my life um danny trejo's
whole career is uh you know until he
becomes kind of this pop culture
phenomenon he's playing certain certain
roles he's pigeonholed into certain
roles this is someone who's who spent
time in in prison this is someone who
overcame addictions he overcame a bunch
of what's to be the who he wants to be
and i love danny trejo afford that so to
use him in this scene it was powerful it
was meta and it was key to the
maturation and journey of boba fett it
was my favorite cameo uh on so many
levels yeah danny trey was still looking
shredded meanwhile he's getting me
chubby all around los angeles he's got
the taco joint he's got the donut shop
but adam i could also say cad bain might
be a fun purveyor of some sort of local
los angelino food i think i'd visit that
restaurant
no i agree and i think the thing with
cad bane that that is so intriguing he
offers an opportunity for
audiences to want to dive deeper into
the world of star wars and i think when
you do that you unlock so many other
things yes you unlock the pike syndicate
but you can also unlock things like
crimson dawn you can also unlock his
connection to characters like obi-wan
kenobi during the clone wars even now
with series like the bad batch like
there's so many opportunities for cad
bane to lead you through a rabbit hole
that can really interconnect you through
so many levels and so many eras of star
wars
and i think the ability to bring
this character to live action now
again if you're kind of been a fan for
all of all the stuff for the last 15 20
years you feel that fulfillment you feel
that joy and you kind of feel
like you've had this promise that was
never promised to you directly
fulfilled and i think that to me was one
of the coolest parts about that
character and the fact that he is also
so
unstoppable and also so sort of um
what's the word i'm looking for he's
kind of unpredictable like you don't
know what he's going to do and i think
if you are someone who likes the kind of
unpredictable characters in a world
where everyone kind of sometimes can
seem like they're very predictable you
have this like cowboy from the west that
you have no idea what he's gonna do i
love that that builds the intensity and
i think that makes the episodes
inherently more intense and it makes the
stakes higher and higher higher so you
have to constantly ask yourself well how
are the heroes of this story gonna
going to defeat someone who is so lethal
and so heartless and so
evil that they're willing to do almost
anything to get the job done
and you know i think that that is on
full display here with a character like
cad bane yeah you know back a few years
ago john fabrer made a movie called
cowboys and aliens we could have just
had cad bane give a ted talk and and
that's
i would have paid a hundred dollars to
see that get a big bucket of corn just
listen to cad bane tell me because it's
a great story in star wars but it's also
an amazing behind the scenes story as to
how cad bane just keeps hanging around
and now you get to see cad in book of
boba fett so ken let's talk a little bit
more because i see that you are on the
wait list for adopting a rancor was that
the case before you met danny trejo's
character yeah i have something close to
rancor it's a chihuahua male uh they
bite the same uh look uh here's what
i'll say again i seriously love cad band
and use of him is amazing uh cad bane
represents this idea of not changing uh
boba fett doesn't change he's cad bane
until the bitter end and i love that but
i think to get to that point boba fett
needs to learn that he can uh recode
himself or rediscover himself and that
comes at this very core moment of him
looking at this rancor who's still a
vicious beast who still needs to be
feared and respected who still
can be violent uh if pushed as we see
and cad bain is the one to push him
there so i just love those beautiful
poetic moments to use danny trejo and
his own life experiences as the rancor
keeper in this keysteam for boba fett
i'll stand behind that but man i do love
that cad bane duster
all right
now we come to your final arguments adam
go first with cad bane i would say cad
bane is an opportunity to show you the
potential of an expanded star wars
universe and i think it also shows you
how someone as lethal as that character
can even intimidate someone like boba
fett a character who we've spent so much
time with trying to change throughout
the series
and i think the the perfect line
delivery that i that i love so much is
ugandan soften your old age and boba
says well we all do and i just love the
fact that these two are able to have
that banter and i think that is such a
representation of what both of those
characters represent whether it's moving
forward or it's kind of staying the way
that that you are but i feel like cad
bane is one of the only characters that
could really put that pressure on boba
fett and put that pressure on the series
and so i think that
along with the intensity of what that
character does and how he just handles
himself and presents himself is the
reason why he ends up being my favorite
cameo
inspiring boba fett to pick up an m
drive shake all right ken your final
argument here you go stumping for danny
trejo's rancor keeper look if you're
trying to be a vegan like me trejos
tacos offers a jackfruit taco that is uh
absolutely beautiful and tasty there no
here i just uh can't take away too much
from cad bang because i love him so much
but i just love the idea of a cameo it
can be silly it could be why is that
person there could be distracting this
one was beautiful uh and it's a scene
that deserves uh to be rewatched and
reanalyzed time after time
you know you meet the the rancor keeper
and you're like okay who is who could
possibly be tame because at that point
we have no idea how what these beasts
are capable of outside of jabba's palace
dungeon and then you see oh danny trey
who's the guy yeah that guy can wrangle
a rancor but then we meet the rancors
and it's like oh no i actually love you
you're intelligent i want to imprint one
too
but then you look at cad bane and you
say again the story behind the scenes
where all due credit to all the great
star wars canon that we got to celebrate
in the 2000s but it's almost
more rewarding in a sense because you
get to see ken baine who was you know
maybe started out playing double a ball
in the minor leagues and then get some
run in a big time series like the book
of boba fett and what an impression
kadman left you put the fear of the
almighty into boba fett it's certainly
going to work for the viewing audience
as well so i'm taking cad bain here and
maybe cad bane can open a pizza joint
here in southern california so that is
the win for adam and now it's two to two
and we are at that moment in binge
battle where we go to a speed round
sudden death finale nfl you're watching
each team gets the ball once and so
you're gonna each get a minute to
support your argument for whatever topic
we have for sudden death and it is
all right you get to uh get in the uh
the
the conference room with a bunch of
higher ups and pitch your show which
character from the book of boba fett
deserves their own series ken who's
getting go picture you go first i'll
tell you i'll give you a go picture here
maki uh we want to go with inves nest
and the cloud writers nymphs nest
portrayed by aaron kellyman and soloist
star wars story one of my favorite star
wars stories i absolutely love what she
represents she's a new face of the
rebellion the rebellion turns into a
military operation at the time because
it needed to but it came from the people
solo shows us the oppression of the
empire on the people and all those
systems that said is enough enough is
enough one of my favorite moments is is
emphasis taking her her mask off not in
a fit of rage in a fit of ah braveheart
speech it's a sigh because she's tired
fighting and she needs help that's why
she reaches out to tobias beckett and
solo in the end and has that drink to
solve it all but you could also get into
some wonderful thing erin kellerman's
great number one the design of infinites
is cool but also you could get into
things that uh you know motherhood she
has a relationship with her mother we
don't know much about that seems where
the legacy comes from star wars is great
in a lot of ways it sometimes suffers in
its analysis of uh mothers in star wars
sometimes like a lot of things they're
killed off for a plot point and i would
love to see that explored more even
though it does look like her mother dies
what's the relationship there what's
legacy legacy she's carrying on how does
she rallies these systems it is uh this
robin hood type thing hyper fuel
represents change it represents hope
that's what she's fighting for and i
think hope uh is the core thing of star
wars hope versus fear and overcoming
fear to find hope that star wars at
memphis nest represents that we got fear
we got hope we got ken knapsock what
more could he ask for and ken with a
great reminder to the audience and your
simpleton host that you can take a
character that doesn't necessarily have
a big or any impression in the book of
boba fett this is which character
deserves their own spin-off series so
adam now it goes to you the final
argument of the day which character
deserves their own spin-off series are
you going with someone that we see in
book of boba fett
i am and i don't know if this is a
reflection of how heartless and hopeless
i am
but i'm gonna go with cat bain because i
think that the thing that really
intrigues me about that character again
it's the fact that he is the greatest
bounty hunter in the star wars universe
but i would love to know how did he get
to that point how did he become the cad
bane that we know and i'm not
necessarily talking about just doing a
show that focuses on his story
cad bean is a character who's been
interwoven through so much star wars
history through the clone wars into the
rebels era and now obviously into the
book of boba fett there is so much that
you can do with this character from his
interactions from characters like anakin
and obi-wan to the to rebel or to the um
to darth maul and all these characters
that we've come to love in star wars so
i feel like he presents a perfect
opportunity where you can kind of walk
through different eras of the universe
and see how the criminal underground has
changed and how being a bounty hunter
has evolved through the different eras
of star wars from the from the old
republic to the age of the empire
obviously not not much into the age of
the resistance because obviously he dies
but i still feel like there's like 30
years of so much great material that
this character could be interwoven into
and really tell the story from his
perspective so we get to understand a
different part of star wars i love the
hopeful and sort of the bright-eyed star
wars but i also am super super intrigued
by
what is what is the dark side of star
wars look like yes we've explored some
of it with the empire and the first
order but i really would love to get
deep deep deep deep underground and
almost go into like a very western
horror
realm and i feel like cadbane is the
perfect catalyst to make that happen and
to explore so many things that we never
got to see
you know and all the other organizations
that exist out there like i would
basically just i basically just want
narcos star wars and i want cad bane to
be the main character in it it's gonna
say the way you're describing i could
really see karen kusama doing something
fun with the series like that so
why do i smell a rematch with these two
gentlemen once the obi-wan series comes
out i don't know maybe that's just my
spidey sense going awry here well i have
to make a decision now and this is going
to determine the match and again this is
why all the pressure falls on my
shoulders and that's why they're just so
weary because
great compelling arguments they were we
weren't even arguing we were just
celebrating all the greatness that was
the book of boba fett at least from my
point of view and so what it boils down
to for me is this i think cad bane is
one of the most interesting characters
and what i love about cad bane is that
you can utilize a cad ban like a boba
fett where it's a conduit to tell more
folks's stories where you can you have
this starting point then you can branch
out to all these different places
however i feel like cad bain could make
a really cool logan-esque film and i
feel like the emphasis hints that we got
in solo just opened itself wide to a
streaming series and it's not just
because i finished yellow jackets last
night it's also because i think emphasis
just
goes so deep in
showing us the hope of star wars and i
think sometimes we need the darkness and
sometimes we need to see that light as
well so by the thinnest of margins i am
going with ken's streaming service but
adam i did give you your own movie with
cad bane so everybody parts
with gifts and the gift of all people
watching today is the celebration of
this thing we love called star wars so i
will start with our big winner here
today ken you wrote the book on star
wars literally why we love star wars
where can everybody out there in the
social media world find you first of all
going to pray for adam and his dark
skull there's some stuff on there i
don't know i love you i love it so much
uh you can find me at cadnab soccer on
my website kenhabsock.com like mark said
uh when i'm not doing comedy on the road
with that mark guy uh you know i'm
hanging out playing rock music on pop
rock and radio and mix cloud all right
ken one word to describe your
anticipation for the obi-wan series
having just seen that poster
uh excitement uh no fancy words just
excitement that that's a good word all
right adam where can everybody out there
check you out and all the great things
that you are doing with heroes reforged
all my social media is just my name adam
lavik twitter instagram heroes reforge
is the main channel that i'm doing
reactions like mark said reviews and all
kinds of stuff we're doing stuff every
single week we're doing reaction videos
we just finished up boba fett we're
going to be doing plenty of stuff for
the rest of the year including the
obi-wan kenobi series
which oh my god your word is
i just i just hope that guy finds his
industrial strength hair drags that's
what he was looking for all right that
is going to do it for us here at binge
battle for adam plavik and ken knapsock
our expert engineer christian ruble caba
his lovely dog draco molly the wonder
dog baxter everybody out there it rotten
tomatoes thank you all for watching here
today
do french fries belong in burritos
that's an argument we're about to have
off air until then i'm mark ellis we'll
see you next time here at binge battle
bring it on